[Music]
there was a lot to be said to getting
off on the right foot and if I could
understand that but I would have wrote a
stronger opening
[Music]
all right folks
Doctor Who list time and this one was
selected from a number of options made
available to my patreon supporters and
they decided this time to have me do a
ranking of the first Adventures of each
doctor now this is gonna be I think the
first that is somewhat related to a
regenerations list because I've been
getting us for a while are you gonna
rank the regenerations and one of the
first things I realized was that ranking
the regenerations in my mind is actually
a three part job there is ranking the
actual instance of the regeneration the
specifics of why it happened and how
that's pulled off there's ranking the
regeneration story as a thing in and of
itself and then there's ranking the
first full story of each new doctor so
nor if left to my own devices that might
have been the order I was doing them in
in this case thanks to patreon we're
doing up first adventures first yeah so
although the to lay it out and be clear
with I think only one exception none of
these are the episodes in which the
doctor regenerates into his newest form
this is simply the first adventure that
the audience gets to see it is not
necessarily the first eventually they
ever went on in the case of a couple of
these or maybe just in the case of one
because of just sort of the nature of
what was going on with the episode but
I'm still gonna put it on here and I
will note that the war doctor I am NOT
including because the first thing that
we saw him in like complete adventure
was they'e the doctor but that is so far
away from his regeneration I don't
really want to count it so that means
I'm gonna be doing 13 of these let's get
started I have a suspicion most people
probably know at least what the bottom
two are gonna be they probably even know
what number one what the number at the
very bottom is gonna be or at least they
think they do
we'll see if they're right number 13
time and the Rani I really did go back
and forth between this one and the one
that's gonna occupy the number 12 slot
as to which one was worse and it was not
an easy call because they're both bad
but this one to me is the worst because
to my mind a first adventure story of
any given doctor has a number of jobs to
do it needs to tell a decent tell a
story worth telling in and of itself it
needs to give us a sense of who this
doctor is so we know who we're dealing
with and it needs to establish any other
major status quo changes that might be
coming along with the new doctor in some
cases as new companions and whatnot now
that's not the case here because mel was
already in place but this thing kind of
fails on all levels because the doctor
as we get him is I really like Sylvester
McCoy as the doctor but his initial
start his first season honestly is not
great and you really get the feeling
that they didn't know how to write for
his version of the doctor yet and he's
fun and energetic but like in a way that
that feels kind of untethered from
everything else going on they'll even
got the actual story with the Ronnie and
this giant stupid brain thing and it's
just dumb it is so stupid and the Ronnie
is such an awful character in this way
she does this ridiculous dressing up as
Mel to trick the doctor and it's like
something out of a Saturday morning
cartoon and you know I say that I know
someone's gonna say this show is meant
for kids you know you don't have to make
something stupid that's meant for kids
Pixar movies are meant for kids they're
not dumb this was dumb and then the
capper on this what ultimately put it in
the bottom place was Mel just screaming
after screaming after and look I get
that she can scream really well that's
actually a big part of why she got that
died she got cast in that role but nope
can't take it anymore so let's move it
up one spot to number 12 the twin
dilemma also not a good episode I would
say honestly possibly slightly over
hated though that's not me defending it
cuz I mean it's my second worst but I
think what I'd say is I feel like
there's additional hate heaped on this
because of how it indicated what the
continuing problems of this new darker
we're gonna be because in my mind the
doctor in in the first adventure gets a
little bit of a pass if it's not in my
mind is ideal if we get right off how
this doctor works and everything I
shouldn't try snapping in these vids
it's a week sound ham there we go so in
my mind it's ideal that the doctor sort
of really gives us a sense of who who
they are how they operate and everything
else but I will give a certain amount of
leeway to post regeneration wackiness if
they if the writers and the actor and
whoever else want to play it a little
bit more off-kilter
I actually think that that works and I
feel like watching the twin dilemma in
isolation I was prepared to buy that
this is not how the doctors gonna be all
the way through this abrasive this
unstable this dangerous like to the
immediate people around him except that
it was kind of how he was for the
remainder of Colin Baker's time on the
show and but I feel like the knowledge
that that wasn't gonna get better
gets heaped on to this episode whereas
in this episode in and of itself I don't
think he's that bad but the story is
boring and the effects aren't great it's
it's not a complete and utter disaster
which I think he gets billed as a lot
but it's jet it just doesn't work this
is boring and it's dull and if the if
you happen to know that this doctor is
not gonna get better during his time on
the show then yeah it's it's kind of
rough across the board number eleven
Doctor Who that being the 1996 TV movie
starring Paul McGann this is the one
instance where we have a regeneration
and first adventure done in one so
this I mean I've done I've done a review
on this one I actually I've done review
of the last two I did as well and I and
I noted in that review that there are
some highlights here McGann himself
being the big one it's all so well shot
but it's very it's very undoctored who I
mean for lack of a better way to put it
it you can feel the American you know
network's hands on the thing in terms of
the way everything gets presented the
way the Masters handled like oh god what
a mess that performance from top to
bottom it doesn't really make any sense
and it's not consistent with anything we
know about the master and inserting all
this weird stuff like the fact that the
doctors have human and then sort of
constructing the plot in this very
mechanical fashion there's stuff that
happens that makes absolutely no sense
based off what we know the characters
but it happens anyway because the plot
requires it to and it's it's just not
particularly effective that said McGann
himself is good in the part you know
thank goodness Big Finish gave him the
stories he deserved and additionally it
does look quite good which it's got over
the two at the bottom so there you go
next up number 10 the woman who fell to
earth not actually this low on the list
because I think there's anything
actively wrong with it there just really
wasn't much to elevate it so like to
compare it in the one eye to the one I
just mentioned you know the reason that
the Doctor Who TV movie is so low is
because while it does have good points
it also has other things dragging those
points down this it doesn't have any
massive fault
I don't feel but it doesn't have any
real severe highlights either there are
a couple little tiny moments that are
pretty good but there's nothing that
makes me go yes that about this episode
and I think lacking that thing that
grabs you and it could have been
anything it could have been the
Companions it could have been the doctor
it could have been the alien could have
been any number of things but nothing
for me at least really grabbed me about
this first episode
13th doctor and as a result despite not
committing any major sins it still ends
up down here number nine
I'm gonna get in trouble for this one
spearhead from space yeah I say I'm
gonna get in trouble for this one
because it look it just I don't think
the Autons are that good I have yet to
see a particularly good story with the
Autons I would love to see one I think
that concept is interesting enough I
just don't think the Autons have been
used very well like at any point not
here not later and the the show is it's
trying very hard to you know to update
everything know the look but the thing
is I honestly I love the p.m. of the
opinion that the leap to color hurt
Doctor Who especially visually because
black and white is really forgiving in
terms of covering up a lot of the seams
and the wonkiness not all of it trust me
there was some first and second doctor
stuff that looked really wonky but it it
can cover up quite a few sins and all
right so the the fact that this is like
ooh in color I don't consider that an
inherently great thing
um / - he's doing a pretty solid job in
this and his dynamic with the Brigadier
right off that helps quite a bit we get
um Liz Shaw who I like well enough but
Joe grant is very much the definitive
third doctor companion and then you know
Sarah Jane Smith came along later so it
you know it wasn't the strongest
companion out the gate it's it's fine
it's like the the bottom three worthy
bad ones ones from here on up are gonna
be at worst fine and that's just kind of
what I feel about this one I know the
classic whose notes are gonna tear me
apart for that ranking next up number 8
the Christmas invasion I basically he
can skip this until about the last 20
minutes basically when the doctor wakes
up again comes out of the TARDIS and
does that all did you miss
me I am on board I love it prior to that
it's okay I mean there's a lot of
emphasis on the the domestic drama you
know with Jackie and with Rose which is
not an element of especially the Davies
era that I particularly care for as much
as I love the character drama the
character drama that wasn't it located
in the TARDIS I didn't care so much for
overall there's some really goofy stuff
the Santa robots the killer tree
I don't need any of that
but once Tennant is in I think this is
one of the best of accomplishing one
what I said was one of the main goals of
any given Doctor Who first adventure
which is to establish who this doctor is
and right off the bat as soon as he has
the ability to start talking just run
his mouth you immediately get oh you are
different but I like it and that works
really well and that's something that's
going to recur in higher up entries
where the preferred the initial
performance was so good it elevates what
otherwise was an OK story speaking of
which number seven robot a robot was Tom
Baker's first adventure and he is great
he was immediately great right off the
bat just that big grin and you know a
little bit weird a little bit like
what's going on with this guy and it's
funny I cannot quantify why I like it
more here than in other places but
classic era Doctor Who camp eNOS tends
to not go up can't camping this in
general is not something I particularly
care for most of the time and something
that depends on really wonky effects
rarely works for me and and it can drag
down something that I otherwise really
liked like the mummies in pyramid from
Mars aren't so laughable to me they pull
me out of this story but there's
something about robot which is really
visually like what how much money did
you have to do this and like just not
good effects at all I think it's just
the fact that the whole notion of killer
robot that at one point grows really
really big is just I can't take that
seriously on its face so maybe that's
why I'm more okay with the fact that
it's not particularly well done visually
because it's not a story I would ever
take seriously in the first place so I
don't feel the camp damage is it maybe
that's what's going on I'm not gonna go
so far as to say that I love the story
I'm just way more forgiving of stuff
that normally bothers me in this is
instance than I would otherwise be
but again what really brings it up is
Tom Baker his performance immediately is
just stellar
next up number six deep breath so this
is Peter Capaldi's first episode and it
is one that I have very mixed feelings
about but a bit like the the 13th
doctor's first story there's really
nothing that is dragging it down but it
has more things pulling it up that for
the first being compiled himself one of
my favorite things about Capaldi was
ultimately the journey that he went on
with his characterization of the doctor
from series 8 9 to 10 and the starting
point is really well established
I adore who found me this face the wood
the attack eyebrows I love that whole
thing I love him trying to figure out
who he is in deciding that the door is
too boring he's gonna go out the window
I love the though just the look on his
fate did that the ambiguity of did he
push that robot off the thing or not
like I'm a little like mmm yeah whatever
but the just something about the look
the performance like doing that as an
ambiguous am like but his performance
and like having just that hint of oh he
looks like he could I really like and I
feel like it I also tend to like the
Victorian setting when it's not saddled
with a story that completely kneecaps it
I like the Paternoster gang they're so
they're on hand that helps and even
though I
come to sort she wouldn't grow on me for
really until about the end of this
series I do think that Clara has better
chemistry with Capaldi than she did with
Smith so that's working better for me
here then it did before - alright
top five number five Rose now there's
actually a few things that I don't
particularly like about Rose I mentioned
already I don't really like the Autons
but Eccleston is great literally from
word one which is just run nice to meet
you rose run for your life you know all
of that I he hooked me immediately and I
think Rose is quite endearing as well
and they have a great rapport right off
the bat and his doctor is he just he a
bit like with Baker's portrayal and with
tenon once he was actually on the screen
in his episode that he conveys who this
doctor is so quickly like trying to have
fun but you can sense the damage just
below the surface with him he it really
does sell him and Rose and this entire
concept because this episode had a lot
to cover more than most because it
didn't have to just introduce a new
doctor and a new companion it had to
introduce an entire new generation to
Doctor Who who may never have even seen
the classic version at all and it does
all of that with an overall story that
is not my favorite and with the whole
thing with the Nestene I'm like am NOT a
huge fan but those other things are
firing so well this works number four
bit of a weird one this Castroville
Allah now the reason this is a weird one
is because I mentioned usually it's
really important that the the first
adventure for the doctor established who
the doctor is and this one doesn't do
that like at all
the majority of this episode the doctor
is completely out of sorts like things
are not working and clicking with him
and he's like the entire plot is that
he's trying to go somewhere to get
himself realign
so this performance is in no way
representative of what Davidson's gonna
do with the part and yet the other
elements work so well because I would
say this is one of the best stories in
Doctor Who that happens to be a first
adventure story so even setting that
context aside this is a really cool
story with what is going on with where
the doctors going in then what is going
on with when he gets there and this has
to also continue the work started in
legatos of introducing us to Anthony and
Lee's master now he kind of had his
first adventure with lagaa plus but we
now need to get a little bit more of him
you know what does he do when he has
time to plan when we get more of an
introduction as to what he's like and so
it's pulling that duty it's got all the
companions to juggle it's it's one of
the more slightly head trippy kind of
episodes which I always appreciate and
even though this performance from
Davison is not indicative of what his
doctor will be it is a very good
performance that he he absolutely sells
every step of the way
number three power of the Daleks so this
is the first story for the second Doctor
Patrick Troughton
now to be fair I'm judging this based
off the animated recreation because this
is one of the lost stories but that is
using the original audio it was done in
a way to make it as much like what the
original intention of the episode was so
I still feel fair judging it by that
and I feel like Trouten he knew how he
was playing this character but he also
knew we're gonna start holding back
because initially this doctor starts out
very quiet and you don't know what to
make of him he's just sort of sitting
there like figuring everything out he
starts playing on a pan flute and he's
throwing everybody off the way the
second doctor so often did but doing it
in a slightly more subversive way than
he would tend to do later on in his run
but I think that just plays up the
mystery of what regeneration even was
this is the first time it happened like
who is this guy what are we dealing with
now and the way that he approaches it
instead of barreling headfirst into
being his version of the doctor and kind
of easy into it with a bit more mystery
it lends a great vibe to this episode
which is already a good Dalek episode in
the first place but in addition to that
we have this is the doctor you were
gonna help us can we trust him to help
us what kind of man is he at the same
time we're dealing with this Dalek story
which is a pretty dang good Dalek story
in itself it's a great just combining of
these elements and it is terrific top
two and if you've been going through
with a checklist once I tell you number
two you know what number one is but you
know we'll get there
number two the eleventh hour the
eleventh hour was the first story for
Matt Smith the eleventh Doctor and it
had a lot to do because new doctor new
companion new showrunner with a new
approach from how Davies tended to do
things and the relationship with this
companion is decidedly different from
what it had been up to that point so
it's not just a matter of introducing a
new character it's introducing a new
character with a new gimmick in a new
way then had really been done so
covering a lot of ground and Matt Smith
nailed it right out of the gate he
embodied his take on the doctor just
right basically as soon as he starts
trying the different foods you're like
oh I get you but like especially when he
picks it shows up in the bowtie says I
am the doctor
it's like yes you are so he absolutely
nailed it but Amelia pond also a
terrific character I still love that
dynamic I love what I love about that is
because he had kind of disappointed her
and let her down when she was a kid
she's both in awe of him but also kind
of over his BS
so it's this wonderful blend of like she
thinks he's awesome but she is not gonna
let him get away with nonsense and she's
gonna call him out on stuff and I love
that dynamic and introducing how that
happened how it works giving it a little
bit of a perspective on her just enough
without actually setting it from her POV
the way that Rose was and that gives us
a companion with with a great sense of
fun and who bounces off this doctor
really really well and a doctor who like
I said just basically showed up already
fully formed which is dang impressive in
and of itself but there was only ever
gonna be one number one and that is in
fact the number one an unearthly child
now normally I consider multi-part
stories as a single thing but I really
do think that an unearthly child even as
a single episode is completely its own
things separate from the what is it ten
thousand BC or whatever the caveman's
story is that sort of follows a after
that if you have never seen an unearthly
child the very first episode of Doctor
Who ever aired on television you need to
because it is a monument to efficient
storytelling in terms of it in its like
24 minutes in 24 minutes it introduces
who were the primary protagonist for the
show initially being you know Ian and
Barbara these schoolteachers it
introduces Susan a student of theirs it
makes it clear why she's unusual why
they are curious about her why they are
concerned about her it introduces the
doctor the nature of his relationship
with Susan the way he treats other
people how prickly he is how bristly he
is it introduces the TARDIS and time
travel this does so much so efficiently
while still giving us characters that
feel like proper
characters and aren't just delivering
exposition aren't just feeding us
information everybody feels like a
proper character from top to bottom and
in a way that some of them wouldn't even
equal again honestly Susan is better in
this than she is at almost anything else
in the entire time she's on the show she
is smart and kind of mysterious and a
little bit off-putting and the doctor so
prickly and you he just has this this
look about I'm like you know so much but
you don't want us to know that you know
so much and Ian and Barbara being
endearing because of how much they care
and just trying to help this child and
all of it there is a reason that this
show has lasted for as long as it has
and none of it would have been possible
without this episode and sometimes when
you go back and look at the first
episodes of some great shows it's not
uncommon to see something that it's like
boy they it's a good thing they had time
to develop that and make it better as
time went on you know go back you know
watch like the first episode of Star
Trek The Next Generation it's kind of
rough but you watch the first episode of
this you know like oh yeah oh yeah you
can get over 50 years of stories out of
this easy and that is why I think
unearthly child is the best first
adventure of a doctor that's my ranking
of these so what's yours how much do you
want to rake me across the coals for
putting your favorite lower than you
thought it should be or something that
you didn't like higher whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it stuff to do
buttons and links patreon I'll plug it
again that's down there plus other links
to other things that I do or
what-have-you
check them out click on them they do
places there's merch all sorts of stuff
but also you don't have to cuz at the
end of the day you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]